En un video anterior vimos que podemos escribir
2/3 x 6 como el número que está a 2/3 del camino
de 0 a 6 en la recta numérica que, como vimos, es
4. Otra forma de pensarlo es que 4 es 2/3 de 6,
podemos ver 2/3 x 6 como el resultado que obtengo
si tomo 2/3 de 6. Ahora, lo que queremos hacer es
aplicar la misma idea, pero no para multiplicar
una fracción por un número entero, sino una
fracción por otra fracción. Así que escribamos
3/4 y lo queremos multiplicar por 1/2, y sabemos,
por supuesto, que el orden de la multiplicación
no importa, esto es exactamente lo mismo que
1/2 x 3/4. Para imaginar a dónde nos lleva esto,
dibujemos una recta numérica bastante grande para
que tengamos espacio suficiente para trabajar.
Este es el 0 y por acá tenemos al 1, y por
supuesto nuestra recta sigue indefinidamente. Y
primero pensemos en 3/4 x 1/2 como 3/4 del camino
a 1/2, así que primero tracemos 1/2 en la recta
numérica. 1/2 literalmente se encuentra a la mitad
entre 0 y 1, tenemos a 1/2 justo aquí. Y ¿cómo
podemos pensar en 3/4 del camino a 1/2? Bueno,
podemos pensar en cuánto es 1/4 de 1/2, es decir,
podemos dividir esta parte de la recta numérica
en 4 secciones iguales: aquí tenemos 2 secciones
iguales y después tenemos 4 secciones iguales. Es
más, dividamos todas las mitades en 4 secciones
iguales: aquí tenemos 4 secciones iguales y por
acá tendremos otras 4 secciones iguales, por
lo tanto, esta distancia que tenemos aquí, o lo
que representa este punto de aquí, es 1/4 de 1/2.
Pero esto no es lo que estamos buscando, queremos
encontrar 3/4 de 1/2, entonces queremos 1, 2,
3/4 de 1/2. Este punto de aquí es literalmente
3/4 x 1/2. Pero ¿qué número es? Bueno, ya
podemos visualizarlo en la recta numérica,
¿pero qué número es realmente? Bueno, una gran
pista es que primero dividimos la sección entre
0 y 1 en 2 secciones iguales, es decir, primero
sólo trazamos 1/2, pero después dividimos cada
sección en 4 secciones más. Entonces, haciendo
esto, básicamente hemos dividido la sección entre
0 y 1 en 8 secciones iguales, por lo tanto, cada
una de estas marcas representa 1/8, este punto de
aquí es 1/8, este es 2/8 y este es 3/8. Y esto es
justo lo que hemos visto sobre la multiplicación
de fracciones, esto debe de ser igual a 3 x 1 / 4
x 2, que es igual a 3/8. Y para no confundirnos,
todo esto de lo que estamos hablando se refiere
a este punto de aquí en la recta numérica. Ahora,
¿y si lo pensamos al revés?, ¿qué pasa si
pensamos en 1/2 del camino a 3/4? Bueno,
empecemos dividiendo el espacio entre 0 y 1
en cuartos, hagámoslo. Tenemos 1/4, 2/4, 3/4,
así que justo este de aquí es 3/4, y queremos ir a
la mitad de ese camino, entonces ¿cuál es la mitad
del camino a 3/4? Bueno, tenemos que dividir
esta sección en dos secciones iguales, así que
la dividimos justo aquí y es exactamente aquí a
donde queremos ir. De nuevo 1/2 de 3/4 nos lleva
justo aquí, a este punto 3/8. Así que de cualquier
forma que lo pensemos, ya sea que estemos tomando
3/4 de 1/2 o podemos decir que vamos a ir a
3/4 del camino a 1/2, o ya sea que vayamos
a 1/2 del camino a 3/4, espero que ahora este
concepto tenga sentido para ti, ya que podemos
visualizarlo y también podemos resolverlo de la
forma numérica, esto nos dará como resultado 3/8.